[Musik]
sind siegfried ermittelt sie es geht hat
meine ansprüche was zeiten angeht
zurückschrauben müssen notwendigerweise
[Musik]
die diagnose krebs war ein schock nicht
nur für frank urbaniok sondern auch für
seinen sohn und seine frau
urban york war 25 jahre lang der
einflussreichste und wohl auch
bekannteste gerichtspsychiater der
schweiz
jetzt ist er aus gesundheitlichen
gründen von all seinen ämtern
zurückgetreten
damit endet eine ära
[Musik]
wer die ära urbaniok verstehen will der
muss zurück ins jahr 1993
am nachmittag des 30
oktober 1991 wurde in zollikerberg die
20-jährige partie führerin pascal
brumann vergewaltigt und ermordet
der täter war kein unbekannter erich
hauert hatte bereits zwei sexualmorde
und elf vergewaltigungen begangen
man hat es hier eindeutig mit dieser art
von täter zu tun die extrem gefährlich
und langfristig lebenslangen behandelbar
sind
es zeigt sich eine solche massive
brutalität und eine penetranz des der
gewalt und der tendenzwende dass
qualifizierte vergewaltigungs
disposition
zusammen mit der bereitschaft zu töten
das ist tief in der persönlichkeit
verwurzelt hat zu ganz vielen delikten
geführt und das ist etwas was dann so
stark in der persönlichkeit verankert
ist dass es da nicht um therapie geht
sondern darum die bevölkerung
langfristig vor deutschen tätern zu
schützen
der fall löste betroffenheit und wut aus
wieso wurden einen solchen menschen
unbegleitete haft urlaube bewilligt wie
so konnte er weiter morden der
justizvollzug war in seinen grundfesten
erschüttert
[Musik]
die verantwortlichen erklärten den
unbegleiteten hafturlaub damit dass sie
hort mit vollzugslockerungen auf die
freiheit vorbereiten wollten
denn trotz lebenslänglicher
freiheitsstrafe hätten sie in bald
entlassen müssen muss ihnen aber sagte
dass in der letzten partie und
strafrechtlich wird kein einziger fall
können eine nie ein lebenslang
lebenslang risk sondern immer noch 15
bis 16 jahre und global water sinkt sind
die unabhängige christen das sind
gericht aus einem urteil ferne und in
dem fall oc c a gehört justizbehörde
hätte verwahrung beantragt der
staatsanwalt hätte verwaltungsgericht
hat die mit dem ausnahme nämlich gruber
new york kam zwei jahre nach diesem mord
in die schweiz und stellte schnell fest
dass diese erklärungen irreführend waren
zum einen muss man sagen es gab gar kein
hinderungsgrund lebenslange
freiheitsstrafen auch lebenslang zu
vollziehen das wäre rechtlich auch
damals möglich gewesen die praxis war
halt anders und zum zweiten war es so
dass die verwahrung die damals
ausgesprochen wurden
dazu führten dass die täter in aller
regel nach drei oder vier jahren
entlassen wurden das führte ja zum teil
zu der paradoxen reaktionen der gerichte
dass die gerichte dann aufgrund dieser
praxis gesagt haben bevor der
gefährliche täter nach drei oder vier
jahren wieder auf der straße steht
beantragen wir lieber eine endliche
freiheitsstrafe von 15 12 jahren dann
ist er länger drin was natürlich das
problem nur zeitlich nach hinten
verschoben hat also diese analyse wenn
man sie so bezeichnen will
die ist ein
ich würde sagen eine die falsch ist und
die eigentlich die wirklichen probleme
eher zudeckt als aufzudecken opfer
wurden lange als unvermeidliche
kollateralschäden einer humanen justiz
gesehen straftaten als
gesellschaftliches phänomen begriffen
nicht als individuelle problematik es
galt die sozialen verhältnisse zu
verändern dann fänden täter quasi von
alleine zurück auf den rechten weg der
ganze strafvollzug war auf
resozialisierung ausgerichtet dass es
menschen gibt vor denen man die
gesellschaft dauerhaft schützen muss war
damals undenkbar
guten abend liebe zu erscheinen und neue
rezepte waren gefragt der gut 30 jährige
urban job übernahm die
themenführerschaft die justiz müsse
potenzielle opfer schützen dafür brauche
es den mut zu harten entscheidungen das
sind täter da geht es nicht um
behandlung um das rückfallrisiko zu
senken das zu tun wäre
therapeutischer größen waren und das
wäre gefährlich da geht es darum das
klar zu erkennen dass zu deklarieren zu
vollziehen und auch lebenslang zu
vollziehen
wir wären das nach humanitären
gesichtspunkten machen das schließt das
nicht aus aber hier geht die sicherheit
der bevölkerung vor er erkannte dass
sich via medien die öffentliche meinung
und politische prozesse beeinflussen
lassen
[Applaus]
im kanton zürich renommiert
gerichtspsychiater frank urbaniok frage
diskutieren mit dem bekannt ist
psychiater von der schweiz frank
urbaniok der frank urbaniok als
professor für forensische psychiatrie
und unterstützt mit seiner arbeit justiz
und polizei zwischen ein mensch so
polarisiert er ist charismatisch in
aachen zu wenig ließ nach hause wo viel
licht ist hat sollte das ist so schwer
zu verstehen was in einem solchen
menschen vor sich geht wir versuchen es
trotzdem mit dem erfahrenen
gerichtspsychiater frack oder man ja
auch hier im studium guten abend
frank kuban york war gefragt nicht nur
bei den medien sondern auch als
gutachter vor gericht bisher von einem
tag auf den anderen aus der
öffentlichkeit verschwand
[Musik]
während seiner erkrankung war
medienprofi urban york nicht erreichbar
für journalisten
es existieren keine bilder aus dieser
schwierigen zeit weil das für mich so
persönliche und so ernste situationen
sind dass es für mich fast ein bisschen
makaber wäre wenn da live noch eine
kamera für die öffentlichkeit dabei
laufen würde und ein wenig ist es
vielleicht auch etwas aberglaube dass
ich das schicksal nicht herausfordern
möchte
seit rund zwei jahren ist er in
behandlung am zürcher uni spital in
regelmäßigen abständen muss er sich hier
untersuchen lassen und dann jeweils auf
die ergebnisse warten
das ist eine situation die ja sehr viele
menschen kennen das da bin ich nichts
besonderes und ich glaube geht es da
auch genauso wie vielen anderen menschen
auch immer so drei bis vier tage vor
dieser untersuchung verlangsamt sich das
leben es wird so wie in zeitlupe und mir
gelingt das dann immer schlechter mich
von dem termin abzulenken dh der rückt
immer mehr ins zentrum meines denkens
und es ist natürlich letztlich ein
eine situation in der ich dann
ausgeliefert bin ich kann selber nichts
machen ich bin dann in einer
warteposition und wartet dann auf die
untersuchung auf das ergebnis das ist
mit erheblichen psychischen druck
verbunden und einer auch einengung des
lebens in diesen momenten aber am ende
muss man sagen auch das sind situationen
die zum leben dazugehören
er hat bauchspeicheldrüsenkrebs
ich kann mich gut daran erinnern ich
habe an einem freitag ein
computerprogramm gemacht ein ct und dann
hat mir der arzt diesem befund gezeigt
und ich wusste sofort was das bedeutet
dass das nicht gut aussieht dass es
schwierig und hässlich wird worüber york
hatte eine statistische überlebenschance
von weniger als fünf prozent
inzwischen ist eine perspektive besser
aber die gefahr eines rückfalls bleibt
erheblich
wir haben jetzt gesagt sechs monate also
ich glaube wir haben fünf im juni glaube
ich jetzt einen termin vor museen länder
zwischen
[Musik]
es stimmt ziemlich gut wenn ich sage das
was ich früher an einem tag gemacht hat
das verteilt sich jetzt auch eine woche
und es gibt da zwischen auch mal ein tag
wie heute mache ich gar nichts urban
york bezieht eine invalidität rente er
braucht jeden tag längere ruhephasen und
ist darum nur noch in einem kleinen
pensum als selbständiger gutachter und
supervisorin vor seiner erkrankung
bestand sein leben vor allem aus arbeit
65 stunden wochen waren normal
ich gehe davon aus dass sich etwas
bewegt habe und mir ist sehr bewusst
dass alles was wir bewegen als menschen
dass es immer bestenfalls ein tropfen
auf den heißen stein ist das ist mehr
als bloß also ich bitte sie an das stroh
vollzug von der schweiz massgeblich für
andere
ich glaube in der tat einige akzente
gesetzt zu haben wie viel das wie viel
von dem mann bleibt wie viel dann in
einer perspektive in zehn 20 30 40
jahren noch da ist ich glaube da ist
immer viel bescheidenheit angesagt ich
viele freunde aber auch viele feinde
gemacht
er gilt als hardliner ja als weg sperre
der nation
thomas mann hat leitet das zürcher amt
für justizvollzug und war urban josef er
hat ihn differenzierter lebt nicht als
pauschalen wegsperren
also ich dank mit dem label wird man
überhaupt nicht gerecht
ich habe mit ihm wohl öfters überfall
debattiert bis in gestritten ohne salat
sich jetzt alle kriege statt und zwar
entwickelt extrem schlimmer fall
natürlich nach jahren noch 215 ja wohl
nicht reichen
ein krieg an als sie zum beispiel das
macht man als 22 uhr tochter seit dem
fall hat sanken die rückfallrate markant
es gilt im zweifel für die sicherheit
schon hier kommt wobei york aus dem
rheinland geboren ist er in köln
aufgewachsen in düsseldorf er studierte
in münster medizin und wurde
assistenzarzt an der psychiatrischen
landesklinik langenfeld dorthin wollen
wir aber urbaniok hat sich verfahren
bitte 100 meter der straße folgen seien
schlechte orientierungssinn ist legendär
auch wege die er jahrelang gefahren ist
erkennt er nicht wieder ein skurriles
detail angesichts seiner sonstigen
brillianz dank navigationsgerät sind wir
doch noch in langenfeld angekommen
zunächst arbeitete er hier mit
suchtkranken dann mit schizophrenen er
landete schließlich in der forensischen
psychiatrie weil ihm angeboten wurde
eine station zu übernehmen und völlig
neu zu konzipieren
diese herausforderung reizte ihn weniger
die forensik an sich damals nicht offen
1994 eröffnete er erstmals einem
fernsehteam seine türen
es ist die psychiatrischen landesklinik
in langenfeld im rheinland die seit
anderthalb jahren neue ideen für die
therapie von sexualstraftätern
entwickelt hat wer hier lebt hat schwere
verbrechen begangen
doch mit knast hat das nichts zu tun wir
lassen uns aufklären
alle patienten in langenfeld haben eine
persönlichkeitsstörung die ihre taten
wesentlich beeinflusste psychiater frank
urbaniok will mit seiner methode an die
wurzeln dieser störung herankommen
neu stand das delikt im zentrum nicht
mehr die kindheit und die therapien
wurden hochintensiv ein pfleger spielt
den vater und der ehemals brutale
sexualstraftäter fühlt wie ein kleiner
junge
videoaufnahmen aus der klinik robinho
könnte das potenzial von therapien aber
auch die ihren grenzen
es gibt menschen das will ich auch ganz
klar sagen da ist es besser die werden
an dem land geschlossen
einfach weil das risiko gegenüber der
gesellschaft nicht vertretbar ist das
waren schöne in der forensischen
psychiatrie
ich bin für diese position zum teil sehr
stark angegriffen ein bisschen
beschimpft worden
man hat mir vorgeworfen das wäre eine
inhumane eine unethische position
das hat zum teil harsche wütende
reaktionen gegeben und ich habe das
gesagt auf seine erfahrung wo ich sehr
konkret mit diesen personen im alltag zu
tun hatte also nicht aus einer
theoretischen position vom schreibtisch
aus sondern aus konkrete arbeit und
damals war das aber eine exoten position
wie vor sagen 'du wirst du sie hat so
carina das thema kindsmissbrauch wir
hart muss man täter strophe und wir in
der schweiz herrschte damals
ratlosigkeit
klar war nur dass sich grundsätzliches
ändern musste um erfahrungen wie sie die
eltern eines missbrauchten kindes
gemacht hatten künftig zu verhindern
er setzt jetzt ein was hätten sie denn
erwartet jetzt das gericht für
entscheider denke schon dass sie
gesperrt wird
also unbedingt die strafe auf jeden fall
nötig sie und wir hätten's gericht den
entscheid begründet der entscheid war
wegen überholens der gruppe bestehe
wegen sehr und rücksichtsvolle doch sehr
hektisch linie an ausgangspunkt zurück
braucht und die zweite punkt ist sie der
monate untersuchungshaft wegen der masse
zugesetzt dass man mit sicherheit
voraussagen machen
da im dorf geschäftlich europa new york
sah seine mission die mehrheit der täter
professionell therapieren um ihre
risiken zu senken und die unbehandelt
barren wegsperren wenn nötig für immer
das ist das thema war natürlich auch
direkt an der bucht kann auch sehr stark
beschäftigen
die annahme der verwahrungsinitiative
gab urban york und seiner mission
rückenwind
im gegensatz zu fast allen anderen
forensischen psychiatern traut er sich
zu tätern eine dauerhafte in
therapierbarkeit zu attestieren
wir reden also war ein ganz ganz kleine
gruppe und da kann man in der tat mit
großer zuverlässigkeit feststellen und
sagen da sind die risiken so extrem hoch
da sind die erfolgsaussichten so extrem
gering dass hier jede grenze der abweg
barkeit überschritten ist das hier die
lebenslangen sicherung im forderung
steht wie gesagt für eine extrem kleine
gruppe das kann man mit großer
zuverlässigkeit sagen mit der umsetzung
dieser initiative tut sich die justiz
schwer aber sie befeuerte einen
paradigmenwechsel den bagno trägt täter
sollen nicht mehr nur für begangenes
unrecht bestraft werden auch potenzielle
risiken sollen erkannt und wenn möglich
weg therapiert werden und die justiz
sperrt präventiv weg wer hochgefährlich
und und therapierbar ist entscheiden
gerichte
gestützt auf psychiatrische gutachten
strafrechtler marcel niki gehört zu den
schärfsten kritikern dieser entwicklung
vom schuld zum treffen zions prinzip das
bewirkt nach wien dafür heute relativ
deutlich dass für apple wenn das delikt
begangen hat der eigentliche gefährliche
mensch im ganzen strafverfahren nicht
der staatssender der forensischen
psychiatrie
das ist gefährlich die menschen was
immer derzeit hat kein glanz und
überprüfbar das ist im wesentlichen
schon über die viehzucht entscheidet
ohne dass airbus verantwortung dafür
übernehmen dass man sicherheit wünscht
desto mehr macht
studiert man seitige struktur und
magister wie das bezahlt also nicht
jetzt finanziell sondern wer 32 risiko
von fehlern und dann ist relativ
gemütlich und behaglich sagen wir werden
das risiko bergen dass oder zu unrecht
und solche haben wir seiten der spieler
und es ist ganz sicher so dass das
pendel in die andere richtung
geschwungen ist und dass man sehr
sensibilisiert für risiken ist und ich
glaube auch an einigen stellen das
system überdreht dass
ist ganz sicher so und da kann man schon
entwicklungen beobachtung wo dann
vielleicht auch durch die prozesse durch
bürokratische prozesse durch immer mehr
abläufe kompliziert halten dass dann die
entscheidung so lange werden so
kompliziert werden dass der eine oder
andere unverdienterweise in dem system
hängen bleibt und das ist genauso zu
kritisieren und rechtsstaatlich genauso
bedenklich wie wenn auf der anderen
seite fehler passieren urban york will
mit therapien und prognosen jeden
einzelfall gerecht werden
das könne es einfach das problem sei
dass dieses potenzial oft nicht
ausgeschöpft werde
darum hat er fotos entwickelt ein system
für risikoeinschätzungen und zur
qualitätssicherung oberjoch arbeitet als
selbständiger gutachter und supervisoren
weit es seine gesundheit zulässt in
diesem fall geht es um einen
pädosexuellen bei dem unklar ist wie es
weitergehen soll verfahren oder weiter
therapieren zwei gutachterinnen die
bisher nichts mit dem fall zu tun hatten
sollen eine empfehlung abgeben
sie haben urbaniok beigezogen was ist
seine motivation in der therapie was wir
erreichen was in seiner erfahrung
was was ist eine perspektive was sagt er
dazu sagt er noch die chance hat also
wirklich arbeit zur körperliche arbeit
machen aber eine stabile braucht auch
etwas für den kopf
wohin ablenkt er möchte aber nicht
irgendwie nie richtig wohl nur aber auch
für die sexualstraftäter sind aber
möchte am schluss um eine art in
möglichst geschlossen
wo er eingesetzt ist das wäre für ihn so
dass er seit klar ist dass
rückfallrisiko des pädosexuellen ist
hoch die t shirt hose capes der maschine
also das ist die typische vorgehens wie
es vor ihm er hat auch schon mal gewalt
mit gewalt probiert aber nicht gemerkt
das ist nett aber es zeigt widerwärtig
probiert solchen ist ganzes spektrum zu
dem was in kenntnisse aus dem ganzen
jahr
seit über zehn jahren wird der mann in
verschiedenen institutionen therapiert
trotzdem ist vieles unklar und paroxetin
das helfe ihm mehr zu verstehen und
geben sicherheit
das hilft ihm mehr zu verstehen
nicht aber das ist nicht das böse ist
hier keine kategorie taten sollen
vielmehr durch umstände und
persönlichkeitsmerkmale schlüssig
erklärt werden
urbaniok spricht vom delikt mechanismus
den es zu verstehen gelte in diesem fall
wieso hat der täter wieder ein kind
missbraucht
ich merke ich habe einen großen inneren
selbst reflektieren große und ihnen
hatten widerstand
das jetzt quasi zu finalisieren im sinne
von es ist dass uns sondern vielleicht
muss man eher sagen es gibt offene
fragen die man nicht weiß
fazit ein scherbenhaufen mit vielen
fragezeichen
ich muss der fairness halber sagen dass
in der supervision bei mir ja oft fälle
kommen die dann problematisch sind oder
irgendwie schwierig sind deswegen ist
der prozentsatz dass man dann da irgend
etwas sieht was nicht richtig ist oder
nicht so ist wie es sein sollte dann
höher
es ist auch richtig dass sich in den
gerade letzten zehn jahren viel
verbessert hat aber richtig ist auch
dass da viel luft nach oben noch ist
europa new york mark kampfsport ist
vegetarier und hat ein teufel statur
ich hab das einfach tätowier ästhetisch
ein total gutes motiv gefunden
sie ist keine tiefere message und
zugehörigkeit zu obskuren organisationen
und sagen was bestimmt ist ein gießener
anlehnung ich bin ein großer fan und ich
finde diese figur des mephisto für das
finde ich interessant aber da ist viel
weniger gedankliche arbeiten als halten
könnte
er hat als student angefangen zu boxen
ihm gefällt es physisch und psychisch
total beansprucht zu werden
auch die auseinandersetzung magier und
das ausloten der eigenen
belastungsgrenze
was mir passiert das im richtigen leben
bedeutet dass ich angegriffen werden ist
schon mal passiert ja und dann habe ich
nicht gewährt und dann bin ich nicht
unter die räder gekommen und wie ist
immer andere kranke noch an ja also war
zumindest ich will man sagen
abgeschreckt und das war beendet aber
ohne dass das jetzt schwere schäden
davon getragen hat und wie ist das
passiert kann ich ihnen zum kontext ein
klassiker
streit um einen parkplatz aber ich war
nicht völlig im recht ich bin einfach
ein geparktes der hat aber das gefühl
ist dass da ein parkplatz ist fühlte
sich total provoziert und hat sofort
sofort angefangen körperlich tätig zu
werden
was leistet sich der neue für musiker
rothosen hat sich lieblingslied ich hab
so ein paar sportler also tote hosen
helfen und bibel ist super weil es genau
sechs minuten ist und weil es die hilft
bei der bewegung es gibt auch ein paar
andere lieder die auch so sind
[Musik]
urbaniok mag auch die intellektuelle
auseinandersetzung
er mischt sich gerne ein sucht wehmütig
die konfrontation und ist ein zäher
gegner immer mit einem großen ziel die
schwächeren vor den übergriffen von
stärkeren schützen sich nicht
einzumischen heißt manchmal dass man
leiden ausbeutung misshandlung und morde
in kauf nimmt und das finde ich kann
keine keine durchgängige position sein
das ist so wie wenn man in der s bahn
etwas sieht und jemand wird
zusammengeschlagen und angepöbelt oder
was auch immer
wo man sagt mich betrifft ist ja nicht
ich mich mich da nicht ein
es ist immer eine frage wie man sich ein
was macht man aber dass man das
ignoriert und sagt nur weil es mich
selber nicht betrifft geht mich das
nicht an
das halte ich für eine position die man
moralisch nicht rechtfertigen kann
viele die er begutachtet oder therapiert
schätzten ihn sagt er seien ihm gar
dankbar aber erhält auch briefe wie
diesen so was sollte man in ein archipel
gulag versenken dürfen und es auch tun
adolf hitler hätte so etwas im zweiten
weltkrieg in auschwitz vergast und in
den ofen geschoben und angefeuert
ein anderer schrieb ihm wissen sie was
passiert wenn ein hochgeschwindigkeits
projektil mit hohem spitz gefüllt mit
quecksilber auf menschliches gewebe und
knochen trifft welcher arzt wüsste das
nicht
für viele opfer ist urban york dagegen
ein held so auch für diese frau die
jahrelang in todesangst lebte sie musste
eine neue identität annehmen und
umziehen um ihrem stalker zu entkommen
ich muss abwarten was sie brauchen und
was hat der frank hohl waren ja auch für
real gespielt jedem fall erst nach
langer zeit danach mit kunstrasen und
machen wir uns im ganzen muss das genau
bekannten zeilen eines missbrauchsopfers
das über obernburg schreibt ich glaubte
dass ihm eine geschichte mein dasein
keine angst machen würde dass er mich
nicht wegen eigener unsicherheit
abnehmen oder alles verharmlosen würde
wie so viele vor ihm auch ihnen hat er
geholfen einer mutter und deren tochter
die vergewaltigt wurde
der 1 vorschreibt die kinder zu
beschützen
und wenn einem die möglichkeit genommen
wird seine kinder zu beschützen
dann steht man vor einer situation in
der man nicht weiß wie man sich
verhalten soll und was man machen kann
um seinem kind oder seinen kindern zu
helfen
ich wusste nicht was ich machen soll was
ich machen kann und man fühlt sich
einfach verloren wenn man opfern danach
ist dann teilt man auch immer etwas von
der wehrmacht mit
das ist ein unangenehmes gefühl deswegen
setzen dann nicht selten im umfeld
schnell gegenbewegungen ein in dem sinne
aber jetzt muss man gut sein jetzt
ist das doch schon so lange vorbei und
vergiss es doch einfach weil es unbequem
wird
und da fängt dann es häufig an das opfer
dann einsam werden oder dann zu wenig
unterstützung haben oder zurückgeworfen
sind auf ihr eigenes schicksal
da glaube ich sind wir eigentlich alle
verpflichtet da unterstützen dazu seien
für die betroffenen
[Musik]
zurück in urbane ochs heimat wo er als
einzelkind in einfachen verhältnissen
aufgewachsen ist
ich würde meine kindheit auch die
jugendzeit und nicht als eine schöne
zeit bezeichnet und hat wahrscheinlich
sowieso immer die tendenz ist ein in
einem glücklichen licht zu sehen
natürlich gibt es immer probleme und
dinge die nicht gut sind und auch
schlechte zeiten aber so insgesamt war
es für mich eine wirklich schöne
kindheit und jugend wird gilt das für
das ganze habe ich würde sagen in der
gesamtbilanz jahr
das quasi erwägt jetzt direkt zu mir
nach hause also sind das jetzt schulweg
also das ist das haus wo ich großteil
meiner kindheit verbracht hat dieses
hier landwirt straße 69
er wurde 1962 als sohn eines
baggerfahrers geboren die mutter eine
apothekenhelferin blieb zu hause
bis der sohn 10 war dritter von unten
das wohnzimmer gewesen
ich habe mich von meinen eltern generell
und auf meinem vater immer sehr
unterstützt gestützt gefühlt und habe
viele dinge richtig gemacht zum beispiel
habe ich als kind immer in erinnerung
dass leistung irgendwas machen das war
immer mit freude verbunden
ich habe mit meinem vater habe ich mit
läufe in wald gemacht oder mein vater
hat mit mehr schafft gespielt oder ich
abends von der arbeit nach hause
gekommen und ich konnte etwas vorlesen
nicht kenne das nicht dass das etwas
kritisches hatte oder etwas negatives
und es war immer etwas machen mit spaß
verbunden mit lust verbunden hat die
dinge immer so genommen wie sie sind in
einer an seine gelassenheit
grundsätzliche zufriedenheit dem leben
gehen gewarnt dass ein nein die
zufriedenheit ist überhaupt nicht eine
stärke von von mir
ich bin dann schnell bei der seite was
kann man auch anders kann man besser
machen weiter entwickeln das ist bei mir
auch wenn ich dinge mache das ist dann
vielleicht kurzfristig aber ich bin dann
fast schon wieder über den
was kann man noch machen was könnte
besser sein wie kann es weitergehen
diese was ich sagen will die bewegung
ja so war er schon als jugendlicher ein
rastloser geist er erinnert sich an
einen lehrer der ihm mit 16 sagte frank
ihnen fehlt die demut über new york fiel
durch überdurchschnittliche intelligenz
auf war aber auch unbequem und
streitlustig sowohl für schüler wie von
lehrerseite es gab immer personen die
das so gut fanden
und es gab auch immer personen offen
lehrern die das irgendwie gemerkt haben
ein problem damit hatten
und das ist sich gezogen haben und
dieses muster kenne ich und das geht vor
allem von nach meiner wahrnehmung vor
allem im beruflichen kontext von männern
aus und das ist dann ohne dass ich das
gefühl habe ich provoziere etwas oder im
konflikt habe wo sich dann vielleicht
personen durch dinge die ich mache und
ich sagen provoziert fühlen und
herausgefordert fühlen ohne dass das
mein ziel ist
ein jux sieht sich als querdenker und
macher der gerne den takt vorgibt und
reaktionen provoziert seine kritiker
nehmen in der gegner als eitel war als
einen der sich anderen überlegen fühlt
und darum zum alleingang neigt marggraf
ist ebenfalls professor für forensische
psychiatrie
er ist obmann jörg freundschaftlich
verbunden aber auch immer wieder
irritiert aber nicht mit dem standard
publiziert kann ich ein messer sicher
frank du kannst alle standard
publizieren
standard werden entwickelt im konsens
von einer fachgesellschaft zum beispiel
ich hätte es mir anders gewünscht dass
man von vorschlag bringt den
fachgesellschaften in wissenschaftliche
fachtagungen was weltweit gibt hat man
erfahrung selten erlebt muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen ich hätte man das make
wünscht es geht um international
association for the treatment auf 611
engeres mit zwei jahren hervorragende
fachtage wurde über näherten halt
abwesend ist und dann halt eben über
tage seien derzeit sache dort
propagieren und ich glaube aus
perspektive subjektiv ist das der
falsche weg
mein weg ist er ein anderes er das
praktische das machen und dann darüber
versuchen praxis zu beeinflussen
wenn etwas funktioniert als in sitzungen
das über papiere und
dann entsprechende abstimmungen breite
abstimmungen verbänden so machen das
stimmt können sie nachvollziehen dass
das teilweise aus arroganz work no wird
ich kann das nachvollziehen dass es so
wahrgenommen wird ich hoffe dass die
menschen die mich besser kennen
das dann besser wissen dass das nicht
eine überheblichkeit ist oder eine
geringschätzung der menschen die sich in
verbänden und funktionen als funktionäre
einsetzen
aber es ist nicht mein primärer weg
einen speziellen weg wählte urbaniok
auch um sich nach seiner
krankheitsbedingten auszeit in der
öffentlichkeit zurück zu melden
ein großes interview in der aargauer
zeitung
drei tage später sollte der vierfachmord
von rupperswil vor dem aargauer
obergericht fahren gibt werden die
zentralen fragen waren ist thomas n
therapierbar
oder ist er einfach für die
lebenslängliche verwahrung am 21
dezember 2015 brannte es in europas wie
schnell wurde klar dass die vier toten
eine frau und drei jugendliche die sich
im haus befanden ermordet worden waren
146 tage wurde ermittelt bis die
verhaftung des mutmaßlichen täters
vermeldet werden konnte
die tat schockierte thomas n verschaffte
sich mit einer list zugang zum haus der
wirt rote die vier anwesenden fesselte
sie erpresste geld missbrauchte den
jüngsten sohn sexuell schnitt an die
kehle durch und legte einen brand das
mordwerkzeug für weitere taten hatte er
bereits gepackt was für ein mensch ist
zu so etwas fähig diese frage sollten
zwei forensische gutachter klären
beide diagnostizierten eine pädophilie
einer zudem eine narzisstische der
andere eine zwanghafte
persönlichkeitsstörung wieso n gemordet
hatte blieb aber offen
vor gericht gehe es nicht nur um
diagnosen sagte urban york ein gutachten
müsse auch das delikt erklären
ich schätze beide gutachter sie sind
sehr erfahren und für ihre sorgfältige
arbeitsweise bekommt dann kam das große
aber ich habe kritisiert dass wenn man
das delikt nicht erklären kann und so
war es damals dass man mit den gutachten
das delikt nicht erklären konnte das
wenn man das delikt nicht erklären kann
dass man dann auch nicht zur therapie
fähigkeit sagen kann dann wenn man nicht
weiß warum jemand eine tat begangen hat
dann weiß man ja auch gar nicht was ich
durch eine therapie ändern müsste damit
das risiko sinkt diese position ist in
seinem fachgebiet eine
minderheitsmeinung es gab applaus aber
auch harsche kritik etwa er tritt als
selbst ernannter ober gutachter auf und
missbraucht seine autorität als
anerkannter fachmann bereits in der
fachgesellschaften und in publikationen
aufgeheizt dass die er nach einer hütte
extreme gegenreaktionen den auslöser
sowie diesem fachgebiet insgesamt ein
schaden eigentlich einmal pro tag vor
prozessbeginn
quasi der gerichtsgutachter an keiner
fragt dann tönt das durch lud groß
gewaltig und ich denke ich grundsätzlich
damaligen vom rv ruhiger prozess nötig
durch mir jetzt wieder prognose machen
weil aufgrund von bisherigen verhalten
würde mir sagen also das scheint das
ziehe ich wusste überhaupt gesagt dass
ich jetzt das verhalten nicht versteht
man sich näher sagte ich verstehe seine
etwa wenn sie ihre durch louis ihre mit
sie nur so hat sie die wale forscht vor
starke reaktionen der stunde nein
erstaunt nicht dass nein erstaunt also
würde ich lügen nicht sagen weil es hat
mich erstaunt es hat mich vielleicht ein
wenig dann doch erstaunt dass nicht ein
einziger auf meine argumentation
eingegangen ist sondern die welle war
dann im spektrum von empörung von
befindlichkeiten von unerhörten die ich
begangen habe
und es stimmt schon ich reagiere ein
wenig allergisch wenn ich das gefühl
habe es geht darum dass man meinungen
verbietet dass man sagt man darf seine
meinung nicht äußern
das überzeugt mich als argument nicht
und da sage ich am schluss wir leben in
einer demokratie leben in der schweiz
wir leben nicht in nordkorea
weltweit sind demokratien auf dem
rückzug
so schreibt urbaniok gutachten artikel
und ganze bücher er diktiert druck reich
unbeeindruckt vom starken gegenwind im
fall rappaz will bastelt er an der
nächsten bombe ausländerkriminalität sei
ein viel größeres problem als von
politik und medien dargestellt
aber es wäre aus falsch verstandener
politische korrektheit tabuisiert die
argumente komma durch die die zahlen
relativiert werden sollen komma sind
nicht annähernd geeignet komma
die zum teil massiv bestehenden über
repräsentationen ausländischer
straftäter zu erklären punkt dieses tabu
biete angriffsflächen für populisten und
sei gefährlich für unsere demokratie
um endras ist urban yorks langjähriger
stellvertreter sascha urban york immer
wieder mit solchen themen zu wort meldet
überrascht ihn nicht
provokation ist so eis verschiedene
aspekte sr ich gerne bis aufwand er wenn
er das wiederum für sich wiese wird dass
er das ganze zivil aber werde frank
kennt wäre die selbstreflexion kranz der
anzug amanda schluss kommt das hat immer
wieder sachen spaß am zündeln am
provozieren
zurück in düsseldorf wo urban york im
hotel an einem buch über den aufstieg
populistische bewegungen schreibt der
mensch sei grundsätzlich empfänglich für
einfache botschaften so sein fazit das
er aus der evolution herleitet seit es
ihm besser geht sind hunderte seiten
entstanden zeigt die er auch mit seiner
familie oder freunden hätte verbringen
können
jetzt im nachhinein viel verpasste spitz
viel weg sie nein weil dass wir fast ein
bisschen unehrlich das bedauern wir das
ist ganz klar ist es eine entscheidung
gewesen die hat vor und nachteile es ist
eine ausrichtung im leben gewesen und
man sagt ja
noch relativ oft wenn ich noch mal
zurück könnte würde ich es anders machen
aber wenn ich ehrlich bin glaube ich
wenn ich dann noch mal zurück könnte
würde ich vermutlich genauso machen die
gleichen gründe die mich dazu geführt
haben in der vergangenheit wären
wahrscheinlich dann auch die gleichen
gründe wieder das leben so zu
strukturieren
diese gründe lassen sich auf einen
einfachen nenner bringen
er mischt sich gerne ein und gestaltet
mit
die jüngsten untersuchungen verliefen
allesamt positiv keine spur mehr vom
krebs aber als geheilt gilt er erst wenn
er rund zehn jahre lang einen rückfall
hat
bis dahin ist es noch ein langer weg der
auch abrupt enden kann
ich gehe davon aus und das ist auch
meine erfahrung jetzt in dieser zum teil
sehr schwierigen zeit gewesen dass für
mich dann
je nachdem wie dann etwas verläuft dann
die wahl das leben selber zu beenden
dann eine wichtige option sein kann
mit der märz ist schluss mit dem habe
ich mich schon auseinandergesetzt haben
[Musik]
auch jetzt kurz mit ihm bei nicht wer
die anderen sind gesetzt musste
absichtliche ich kenne dich ich hasse
dieses breite bahn york hat zwei
inzwischen erwachsene söhne
die seine frau mit in die beziehung
brachte und aufzug während er vor allem
arbeitete yannick ist 20 und teilt die
sportbegeisterung seines vaters durch
seine erkrankung hat sich die bedeutung
von arbeit und leistung relativierte new
yorks leben seine prioritäten haben sich
verschoben
der beruf ist heute ein wichtiger
nebenaspekt die familie und einige
wenige freunde
die hauptsache
super
die theorie
danke frank mein arm hat mich besiegt
hat beim wein habe ich dich
auch mal
guck mal
ein cd rom tot ich habe auch angst vor
dem tod aber wie das ja viele andere
sagen und viele betroffene aus
vielleicht angst dann noch mehr vor dem
sterben vor dem wie das dann ist
natürlich ist mir der ist der tod viel
mehr in meinem leben gerückt in der
vergangenheit in den letzten zwei jahren
noch mehr aber auch in der zukunft der
ist viel präsenter in meinem leben hat
zuvor gewesen ist aber im großen und
ganzen also ich weiß klingt jetzt sehr
glatt wenn ich das sage gehört seit
leider zum leben nation am 8 die
schulter also hier verhindern nacken ist
ja ja
[Musik]
ein co